we have yet another very important
Supreme Court decision the Supreme Court
has ruled that Donald Trump cannot shut
down daca and this is an important
decision to understand both because of
what it does say and because of what it
doesn't say actually so as a reminder
daca is deferred action for childhood
arrivals the idea is that there are
people who came to the United States
illegally when they were underage they
were not adults and they were brought by
parents and daca is essentially a
program which says we are not going to
deport individuals who even if they are
adults today as some of them are came
here when they were children not by
their choice not because they said I'm
going to do something which I know is
against the law but because they were
brought here by their parents and it's a
completely logical program and Donald
Trump promised
it's another failed promise Donald Trump
promised when he was running for
president back in 2015 and 2016 he said
he would quote immediately terminate the
executive order by former President
Barack Obama which he called illegal
amnesty for hundreds of thousands of
young immigrants about 700,000 folks in
fact potentially would be affected by
terminating daca and the Supreme Court
has decided it's not happening but the
devil is in the details and the reason
why the Supreme Court decided this is
very important it was a five-to-four
decision Chief Justice John Roberts a
George W Bush appointee wrote the
majority opinion along with the for a
more liberal members of the Supreme
Court and they wrote in that decision
quote we do not decide whether daca or
it's rescission are sound policies we
address only whether the agency complied
with the procedural requirement that it
provide a reasoned explanation for its
action so this is like the the most
important thing to know the court is not
deciding whether or not the policy is
good or bad and the court is not
deciding whether there are other cases
Trump could make to end
Dokka all the court is saying is that
Trump's argument was a bad one
incredibly this again comes down to the
Trump administration is sort of
incompetent the way they are making some
of these legal fights go is setting them
up to lose Donald Trump's argument was
that when Barack Obama created and
maintained the program he was operating
beyond the legal power he has as
president that was the argument that was
made the supreme court looks at the
argument that is made and the Supreme
Court decided now Barack Obama had the
power to do this and he articulated
reasons why he did it and we aren't
deciding whether we believe politically
they are good or bad reasons or
economically they are good or bad
reasons
Trump's argument was Trump the Obama
overstepped authority and the Supreme
Court determined that that is not the
case this should be a warning to us that
Donald Trump could try to revoke daca
again and formulate the argument
differently Donald Trump if he were
better and his lawyers were better at
filing documents essentially they could
have made an argument that the Supreme
Court very well may have upheld and said
go ahead and end daca so this is another
reminder of how urgent and important it
is to remove Donald Trump in November
before he can appoint more people to the
Supreme Court and before he can again
make what will probably be a stronger
legal argument what could be a stronger
legal argument for ending daca now there
are a couple of people writing to me and
I see them posting on Twitter and
elsewhere saying you idiot leftists who
think you've got to vote for Biden
because of the Supreme Court look at
this Supreme Court which made the
decision you guys want on LGBT
discrimination last week and now they
made the decision that you want on the
issue of daca this time around the
argument they are saying that we must
vote Biden over Trump because of the
Supreme Court is a dumb argument they
say because the Supreme Court decided
the way we would have decided
on these two cases and there's a couple
of really important things to point out
here number one the way that this ended
up going Obama's way on daca rather than
Trump's is because Trump's argument was
a dumb argument it was just a bad legal
argument there's a very good it was such
a dumb argument that even a conservative
Supreme Court had to find this as the
outcome and remember Gorsuch and
Kavanagh both said yeah this is a good
enough argument to get rid of daca so if
Donald Trump was able to put together a
better argument on getting rid of daca
it would probably be gone right now
there's a good chance that it would have
been it would be gone right now that's
number one number two the LGBTQ decision
did go the right way but Cavanagh what
was wrong on that one I mean other okay
Kavanagh voted but with the minority on
the LGBTQ decision and so did Gorsuch on
and Gorsuch on this one along with
Kavanagh so the idea that we don't have
to worry about the Supreme Court because
these two decisions went what we
consider to be the right way is an
absolute and total joke only one of
trumps picks made the right decision on
one of these two cases otherwise you're
talking about appointees from other
presidents so if you're saying we don't
need to worry about judges in thinking
about Biden versus Trump 2020 you're
living in a fantasy world you're living
on a planet that I certainly don't don't
recognize and if anything these two
cases when you really look at the
details reinforce the case for judges
and the Supreme Court being of critical
importance in what we do in November
okay Donald Trump again is saying that
coronavirus is dying out and it's just
going to go away Donald Trump was
interviewed yesterday about his upcoming
rally in Tulsa Oklahoma disastrous idea
dr. Anthony foul he says I wouldn't go
to any large events including this rally
just not a good idea not a smart idea as
a pandemic is still continuing to rage
Donald Trump said now the rallies fine
because coronavirus is dying out
coronavirus cases
rising in 22 states including Oklahoma
where you plan to hold a big rally this
week aren't you great about people
getting sick no because if you look the
numbers are very miniscule compared to
what it was it's dying out by the way
well doing very well in vaccines and
therapeutics also I think there's going
to be some big announcements on that in
the not-too-distant future but no we're
not concerned actually Oklahoma has had
a very low rate relatively speaking it
is a little spike a small spike for a
specific reason but no we had over a
million people apply they have people
now days ahead lined up they have big
lines of people so Trump said the
numbers are minuscule the numbers are
not minuscule
we were at one point seeing 30,000 new
cases a day we are now seeing 23,000 new
cases a day that's not minuscule as I've
already told you a bunch of times this
week many states are seeing record
spikes Texas Florida Arizona etc we have
more than 20,000 new cases every single
day people being diagnosed with corona
virus but there is something that is
truly chilling about Donald Trump saying
it will eventually go away eventually it
will go away and his followers are so
ignorant and so desperate for Donald
Trump to be right that Trump in a sense
is correct it will eventually go away
and his followers are just ignorant
enough that they might give him the
credit for it or at least say look Trump
was right all along now let me explain
what I mean by that eventually even
without a vaccine eventually if the
virus keeps spreading and spreading and
spreading you're going to get to 70
percent of the country getting the virus
and that is the threshold that is
believed to be the threshold for herd
immunity for something that is
contagious to the degree that
coronavirus is contagious now this is
important to understand herd immunity is
not a fixed number for a more contagious
disease you need a higher percentage of
immunity to get to herd immunity so
measles is so contagious that the
estimates are you need 95 percent
immunity
to have herd immunity coronavirus is
less contagious as far as we know than
measles dramatically so and so it is
estimated that you need about 70%
immunity now that could be a combination
of vaccinations and people who've got
and recovered from the disease we don't
have a vaccination right now so in order
to get to 70% we would have of 330
million Americans 230 million would be
infected with a roughly 0.7% infection
fatality rate that means about 1.6
million people would die so Trump is
right eventually it will die out because
so many people will have gotten it that
somewhere around a million and a half
will have died and we will have herd
immunity
that doesn't mean Trump is handling this
correctly that doesn't mean it makes
sense to have a crowd of 10,000 people
in Tulsa Oklahoma on Saturday and it
certainly doesn't mean that Donald Trump
deserves to be reelected so my view
continues to be if Trump gets another 12
to 18 months this could wind itself down
on its own leaving untold death in its
wake and you will have trumpets who will
be reinvigorated and say Trump said it
would go away and it went away I guess
he was sort of right we can't take any
chances on that Donald Trump needs to be
removed in November we have four and a
half months until the election and then
it's two and a half more until he would
be replaced with Joe Biden meaning in
seven months total right we're talking
about January 20 21st 20th we could have
Trump gone coronavirus will in all
likelihood still be a problem at that
point in time but we could at least
start to start to go back to something
that would actually resemble sanity at
that point in time in terms of the
decisions you have to make over the next
two weeks I would go without you over
Trump if you would go with Trump over
fowey I want to know why if Trump says
it's safe to go to a rally with 10,000
people and foul she says it's not I'm
going with pouchy I also live in
Massachusetts where there are no rallies
of the size taking place there are no
events of this size taking
and that's a very very good thing we
have a fantastic program coming up for
you today
I will remind you that you don't have to
just watch clips on YouTube or Facebook
if you don't want you prefer a daily one
our audio podcast it's available for
free on iTunes stitcher google play
Pandora Spotify etc I think I'm
forgetting some and I encourage you to
subscribe to the podcast you can also
let me know your thoughts about what is
safe and what is not safe as of right
now on Twitter I am on Twitter at D
Pakman you can find me there just don't
troll me please don't fold the David
Pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
everybody i'm going to thank today is
named john today's new members of the
day are john Condrey and John Skinner
and today's longtime sustaining member
of the day is John did Domenici so
thanks to all John's literally people
named John I'm not using it in terms of
the prostitution sense including our new
members and our longtime sustaining
members of the day you can grab a
membership at join pakman.com it is
cheap it is easy it is quick you get the
bonus show you get the commercial free
audio and video streams the Members Only
newsletter it's just great if there's
nothing better the only thing better
would be maybe some nice cold watermelon
on a hot day but short of that
membership is just the best ok let's go
to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 and
see what is on people's minds oh let's
go to Brody from Dallas our friend Brody
from Dallas who has written the guide on
how to call into the show what's going
on Brody hey David I'm pretty good how
are you doing good awesome hey so I know
that Bernie Sanders has asked his
supporters as have you spoken on your
show about the proper direction in which
to go as far as getting our police more
accountable yes our communities safer
and doing it in the right way the
question I have for you today is when
people who see that say that look we've
tried voting we've tried activism
we've tried legislative mechanisms we've
tried to digital mechanisms and now
that's works when people who
come to you and say hey David I think
that using a mechanism like a ballot
initiative or defunding to force people
to come to the table to negotiate for a
different type of Police Department is
the way to go what would your response
be to that well
III would reject on principle this idea
of we've tried it there has not been I
mean listen when you're talking about
police departments this has to do
primarily with with three things it has
to do with police chief's who are in
most places appointed by mayor's so
where have been the big movements to
hold mayors accountable for who has been
selected as police chief I mean I'm sure
we can find some examples but there's
been no major movement to say elect
let's put in place the right mayor's
make police chief selection and police
policy a huge part of those mayoral
campaigns I've been involved from the
media side in a bunch of different
mayoral races and it's just it's just
never been a thing so then you've also
got a look at governor's because a lot
of funding for police is state funding
for both state and local police we
finally heard from Andrew Cuomo with
some ultimatums when it when it comes to
police but I would just reject the idea
that we've quote tried it now if we
reject the idea that we have tried it
would that mean that if there is a
ballot initiative or a push for a ballot
initiative such as one that for example
is coming up where I am in the area in
Fort Worth to restrict a portion of the
funding that goes to SWAT and things
like that
would you support a ballot initiative
which it is on the ballot and I don't
mean would you support it one way or the
other
would you support letting voters have a
say oh yeah of course I mean so there
there is a question as to whether you
want to vote on civil rights right so
when we talk about hey should gay
marriage be legal I am skeptical about
letting people vote on those things and
and people have voted the wrong way when
it comes to how tax money should be used
I am very much as a general rule in
favor of letting the people have a say
so while I don't think
the police is the solution if the public
has said we want this on the ballot then
of course that that it should be on the
ballot absolutely all right are there
any other mechanisms that you would
suggest in terms of the size of looking
at governor's and who makes these
appointments that people can look at in
terms of making directly positive change
in their community yeah I mean I think
it's getting involved so when you talk
about lobbying city councillors I mean a
lot of people we have to turn the
internet activism into actually getting
involved in in a local way because the
national movement around this is great
for energy but the national movement is
not going to make you know the Back Bay
neighborhood of Boston necessarily
demand or achieve change so I think it's
we've got to translate that in the same
way that like we've got to turn the
protests that started when Trump was
elected into voting in November if we
want to turn it into something we have
to take these protests and turn it into
a very very specific and calculated
local activism awesome well hey I
hopefully I lived up to the guide that i
created for calling in and i appreciate
the the information and I'd love to
shown that keep it up and thanks for all
the hard work dude all right Brody great
to hear from you always great to hear
from Brody let's go next to our caller
from the 3:03 area code who's calling
today from 303 hey Richard what's up
well become progressive I moved to
Colorado about five years ago and I
think I have to put a quill - no go to
any Senate and or congressional
committee and just you know make a pitch
but my question to you that goes farther
that builds on what - what I just said
is that are you willing to go to the
barn in campaign now that very question
I have no idea what you're talking about
your so let me see if I understand
you're willing to go to the Colorado
politicians and ask them for things you
want that was the first thing you said
right correct okay
you're saying and I will am I David
Pakman willing to go to the Biden
campaign and ask them for something I
mean I'm gonna be honest I'm not a
journalist so I don't have the schedule
of where the Bartlet campaign will be
from day and day now I'm not that in I'm
not that focused on that campaign okay
I'm sure it darling I might as well just
painted up that that quest to you if
you're interested if you're not
interested I get it you have stuff to do
but after being in the Denver protests
of getting tear gas and pepper spray I
wasn't really a big fan of that so I did
some deep dive thinking and I came to
the realization that maybe maybe just
maybe two DEA become progressive what
would it look like who would it who
would run it or there any agencies that
will compound onto the DEA for
scientific exploration what what could
the DEA become what rather than just
being an enforcement arm of the Justice
Department and Richard is this now is
this a different topic now than will I
go to a Biden event and ask him a
question I'm sorry I'm just trying to
keep up well I'm trying to figure that
answer out I'll let you decide if it's
two different issues but if you've got
or if you're in the press box existe
have the opportunity to ask that
question maybe maybe it's the same
question I don't want maybe it's the
same company
all right well Richard let me look into
that okay all right thank you all right
ma'am Richard we've taken detailed
copious notes and we will we will
investigate let's go to 9 1 9 yang guy
who is voting for Biden 909 yang guy
voting for Biden does that does that
ring a bell yeah how you doing hey how
are you I'm doing all right I just want
to know what you think is the best way
for us to make some positive change as
progressives under the Biden
administration
beautiful
excellent so let's imagine November 3rd
assuming we know the results on November
3rd we may not November third Donald
Trump is removed it is the end of an
error and the start of starting to the
start of fixing the reputation and
infrastructure and governmental
functioning of the United States with
the election of Joe Biden ok very
optimistic scenario that moment the
David Pakman show becomes a show not
about removing Trump but about making
Biden the most progressive that we
possibly can so the question is a
beautiful question so as soon as this
happens we have to put pressure on Biden
to actually do the executive orders that
he has said he would do when he gets
elected president every one of the
changes he's promised to healthcare we
need to push for immediately and then
push for more in the midterms of 2022 we
need to make the house and hopefully the
Senate as left as we possibly can I mean
it's like the way I see it is when if
and when Joe Biden replaces Donald Trump
that's not the end that's the start when
it comes to the progressive movement
which has been playing defense for a
long time now because of Donald Trump we
we haven't had the ball yet right in
that so it's like imagine a football
game we're we could potentially get the
ball back in November we've got to then
start calling the right plays to use a
sports metaphor okay yeah that works out
great cuz I'm thinking about like as far
as everyone start by by VP pick and I
think that the best one to get some
progressive change at this point would
be Elizabeth Warren and I just wonder if
when we do put the Senate and everything
that we do have the ball if you know the
politicians and us will be able to
actually get stuff done as opposed to
like returning to the Obama years well
that's going to be up to us that's going
to be up to us it's going to be up to
who we elect at the state level who we
put in place in the Senate and in the
House of Representatives so the fight
will hopefully begin on January 20
first yeah let's hope so let's alright
my friend thanks for the call very much
appreciated
that's a Yank guy who has decided that
he must vote for Joe Biden that that is
the right thing to do let's go next to
our caller from the 9 7 8 area code
caller from 9 7 8 what's your name and
where are you calling from
I'm calling from westminster
massachusetts westminster where is that
i we are in central mass for like 20 30
minutes away from western depending on
faster-growing
alright I would have imagined that was
the 508 area code out there no no no
we're like a little farm town all right
what's going on um well I just wanted to
know what your take was on the recent
conflicts that been bubbling over with
China and India alongside the bombing of
the diplomat center and the DMZ and if
you think that there is a plausible
scenario where we might blunder into
another global military conflict you
know I this could be me being naive but
I I actually feel pretty confident that
it is not going to blow over into a
major conflict the likes of which you're
suggesting but I do think that you know
we can't control who's in power in China
or in India nor should we but you know I
would feel better if we had someone with
a steadier hand running the United
States than Donald Trump and obviously
there's going to be a lot that happens
before Joe Biden could even possibly be
sworn in if he were to win in November
so I am hopefully not naively confident
that this is not going to blow up but I
would feel better if we had I mean
listen you can say a lot of things about
Joe Biden he's not super progressive do
we need another 78 year-old you know all
this stuff Joe Biden in terms of
diplomacy and knowledge of China and
India blows Trump at of the water by a
hundred times we may not agree with all
of Joe Biden's conclusions but I think
Biden's instincts would would be the
right ones when it comes to that region
in preventing this type of conflict he
may not do what we like on trade I mean
I'm not saying Biden's great on China
period but he's a steadier hand and he's
a diplomat and I would feel better
having him in the mix than Donald Trump
right I agree I one of the major
concerns that I had with this like and
its entirety was that you know all the
you know progress that president now
made with you know actually trying to
bring more of like a you know economic
flourishing to North Korea and all the
sudden all that for like him you know
even it's just the optics of this and
walking over past the DMZ into North
Korea like the first for the first time
in like now they're pretty much saying
no screw that we don't you know we
didn't get what we wanted now I feel
like Trump's ego is going to get ahead
of him and he might do something stupid
well listen from the get-go
all of these right-wingers who were
saying you know people are making fun of
Trump but he knows what he's doing when
it comes to set of North Korea he's
gotten concessions and he's made more
progress than this that only someone who
completely misunderstands or doesn't
know the history of relations with North
Korea could have imagined that Trump was
actually you know exhibiting or being
party to some major breakthrough with
North Korea and obviously that in the
last two years that's been proven to be
the case so yeah I mean if you're
waiting around for Trump to be the guy
that solves that situation it's
obviously not going to be him yeah of
course
all right my friend thank you so much
appreciate the question great to hear
from you let's take a quick break but if
you're holding don't hang up
unless you want to get off the phone
because I am gonna be going right back
to the phones after this short break the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him welcome back to the
David Pakman show
okay let's go back to the phones at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 see what people want to
talk about we'll go to our caller from
the 6 to 6 area code who's calling today
from 6 to 6
hi David my name's Steve hey Steve
what's going on not much appreciate your
show so thanks for what you do my
question centers more around up so I'm a
very big progressive and I was a huge
Bernie supporter but at the end of the
unit sorry at the end of the day like
you I recognized that the moment that
we're in with Trump in office and we
can't just take a chance but it occurs
to me that given everything that's
happened with coronavirus and of course
oh boy a lot of accent in the car down
there I'm sorry I'm trying to cut this
call um what could it be in retrospect
or even now since we're doing this
election with Biden is Biden the right
candidate overall for the moment because
he's seems more normal yeah is he the
right committed it is he an acceptable
candidate is he the best candidate are
all different questions right so like
you as a progressive myself I'm to Burke
to Biden's left I would like to have
someone more progressive that's question
one is Biden the ideal candidate from a
political standpoint would all else
being equal without being ageist do I
think that we need to replace an old
white guy for lack of a better term with
an older white guy I don't know I mean
it's like okay you know I'm not I'm not
ageist or it's
not really a question of of that but
it's it's more just like is this the
direction we should be going at this
point or do we need something that we
might call a kind of reinvigorated young
leadership maybe but is Biden an
acceptable choice given the
circumstances yes I mean he's acceptable
enough and that he's better than Trump
and that's who I'm going to vote for
right no no I understand that and I
fully agree a I guess more you know with
as you cover your covering polls from
Arkansas he seems to be down only by two
by the does and you see him very
competitive in states that a more like
Bernie Sanders versus I don't have in
him being competitive in Arkansas and I
don't think fighting will win Arkansas
but all these polls uh suggest
double-digit leads for Trump
I don't know that if Bernie were and of
course we still have to win we can't
count our chickens before they hatch
rather but I guess I don't imagine
Bernie doing as well in the polls if he
were the nominee even though he's my
preferred guy it's I I don't know the
answer to that I mean it's you know what
you it's one of these counterfactuals
that is indefeasible in the sense that
what can we say you know back in 2016
you had a big crowd of people saying
Bernie would have defeated Trump if it
had been Bernie instead of Hillary now I
mean you know you have people saying
Bernie would be doing better against
Trump but at the same time Bernie did
very poorly against Biden but or even
early on Bernie was down by two million
votes I know it ended up being much more
but that was after Bernie dropped out so
I don't I don't know that we gained much
from the analysis because we can't
possibly know the answer yeah no no fair
enough no that makes sense that was
something I was thinking about but by
the way I appreciate the work you know
you your voice sounds just like MSNBC
Steve Kornacki this is not Steve
Kornacki right no no no absolutely not
all right very good
okay Steve thank you so much for the
call I appreciate thank you have a good
day okay take care let's see let's go
next to our caller from the 6:00 to 3:00
area code who is calling today from 6:00
to 3:00
uh hello yeah that's you oh hi this is
Ricky from Phoenix so I have a question
I saw the question because they Leon
yourself in saying uh there's gonna be a
taboo talking about religion and
politics
in the table right um so yes I've been
trying to talk to people like you know
like at work and you know my family my
friends about politics and they get
really super mad so I'm just like well
we should probably have these
discussions now because it is kind of a
bad time so how would you approach that
well what do they get like give me an
example so Ricky you decide to bring
something up with like a family member
what do you bring up and then how do
they respond so when the stimulus sticks
came in and Trump had a letter with the
stimulus chicks come in like in the mail
yeah there were like oh this is a nice
thing to do it's like don't you think
that that's a bit propaganda and they
are gone mad I mean they're all like
less supporters but they don't know
anything about politics so I just
brought their question like don't you
things a bit propaganda so here's an
idea on that one that's a good that's a
good one with the way you might approach
it would be instead to try to get them
thinking instead of saying don't you
think that this is just propaganda you
could say that's interesting you know
everything the government does costs
money do you think this is a good use of
taxpayer money to send these letters and
then maybe they say yeah I do and then
you say okay that's interesting how do
you decide if something is a good use of
taxpayer money the point is it's not so
much about which questions you ask but
just get them thinking about how they
came to these conclusions because I
agree with you this letter is is totally
propagandistic but by starting to call
it propaganda I probably won't convince
too many people instead if I get it to
think about we have limited funds you
know if they care about debt say we're
in debt we have a pandemic this cost
money like this is you're saying this
isn't it this is a good okay use of
money when the money could have gone to
something other than sending all of
these letters out to people I would
maybe approach it that way than just
calling it what I buy the way I agree
with you it's propaganda but yet you
probably aren't going to convince too
many people like that
no because you know I do say some things
and I do think I'm on the ball when I
come from my response I'm just like
maybe a kind of approach there a
different way
yeah do you know it's good to be
thinking about it about that listen
Ricky Arizona
one of the worst coronavirus case growth
rates in the world right now how are you
living it down there is it if my friends
in Arizona are saying it's like business
as usual just everything's open and
nobody's wearing masks yeah no I worked
at a sound Club right you know right but
I mean gonna happen we don't have a mask
policy going on everybody's going out
freely everybody's going to the gyms
it's really really bad like I recently
went on a date and we went and we went
to like a lake me my date and then
nobody was wearing masks people weren't
social distancing so it was kind of
worrying for us
I mean we did try to just social
distance places thank you friends said
it's business as usual nothing is
changing at all our people even talking
like our people so there's people who
are not wearing masks as if everything's
fine and nothing is going on
there's also people who are sometimes
not wearing masks because they're aware
of what's going on but they think it's
like a hoax or not not really a problem
which is it more of would you say people
who are just like on cloud nine and
aren't even aware or people who have
decided like I don't need to wear a mask
right now it's I don't need to wear a
mask I think the majority of people I
talk to I don't need to wear a mask oh
yeah Wow all right Ricky good luck down
there in Phoenix thank you and good luck
I'm a fan of the show I've recently
became a member so thank you I
appreciate that too all right Ricky take
care great to hear from you
we're all still we want to go let's go
to the 202 area code haven't heard from
the 202 for a little while who's calling
today from 202 is illusion
hey loosen what's going on all right so
you talked a lot of people talked about
you know if spigen gets elected is Trump
gonna stay in the white house all that
sort of stuff
my question is between the election and
when the delegates actually cast their
ballots which is a process I'm not very
familiar with is there area there for
tinkering by any member of the
Republican Party state governors
attorney generals to sway thing to
change some of the votes because I know
some delegates don't necessarily have to
vote
or who the citizens have elected so I
think you may be confusing two things
it's a good question but let's first
undo the confusion you've got the
Kannamma nating conventions which are
based on delegates that is like the
republicans select their nominee and the
democrats select their nominee what
happens after the presidential is
electors are I believe it's on December
14th but I'm not totally sure where they
go and they formally say from the state
of Massachusetts you know we give our
however many electors we have to Joe
Biden or whatever the case may be there
so it were you a little confused about
the two of those because you were kind
of mixing up the language I just got the
terminology wrong okay got it okay so
but so we're talking about the December
electors right okay so there is this
thing called the faithless elector and
the idea is that if you have a situation
like we had in 2016 where the public
elects a lunatic who's completely in
over his head and unfit for the job
there is a mechanism that would give the
electors leeway to become faithless
meaning they lose faith in the way that
their state voted and to select a
different person and there were rumors
and even some claims in 2016 that it was
going to happen and they weren't going
to vote for Trump and it didn't happen
obviously Donald Trump got his electors
and and he became president so is there
the possibility that an attorney general
a governor someone could get to the
electors and try to strong-arm or coach
yeah it's it's all possible I don't
think it's going to happen and is do the
electors have to give all the electoral
votes or are they broken up like it's if
there's 13 electoral votes they can get
it they can throw one the other way yes
if a status 13 electoral votes there's
13 electors and each one would get a
vote okay yeah all right my friend thank
you great to hear from you a lot a lot
of good calls this week I must say let's
go to our caller from the 9/5
for area code who's calling today from
954 hey David Lewis from Miami Florida I
have a similar I guess situation as the
gentleman from Arizona
yeah I hear Miami's kind of like
business as usual everyone's kind of
treating like the coronavirus like a
phase like a like a blues springtime a
problem now it's summer and you know as
I saw the news like everything's kind of
a pointing to like almost like a second
wave and I just wanted to get your
thoughts on I like how do you what's
your outlook on on kind of the way
people are taking this cuz I guess
Miami's kind of a mix of everything yeah
but it seems like everyone's starting to
go out what a restaurants more you know
people are shaking hands like the whole
mass thing is like a people will I talk
to more conservatives they say it's a
hoax right I just want to know like
where do you think this is gonna end up
two months from now three months from
now well listen I'm glad you called
because I want to talk about Miami
Miami's one of my favorite places within
the United States the vacation so let's
get to Miami in a second so the the
situation is there's no one answer right
now what we're seeing in some states is
very different from others here in
Massachusetts and I'm not bragging when
I say this things really are going very
well there's some days where we only
find 50 cases and I'm glad that I'm here
and not in some of these other places
now things could turn around we'll see
if the protests had any effect on cases
outdoor dining has opened up we'll we'll
see what happens but we are getting
dramatically different situations in
some states versus in other states the
states that are now spiking so you've
got Texas Florida Arizona and some
others they may not have a second wave
because the first wave just won't end
right the idea was that by June first
cases would be down dramatically in the
country and they're down a little bit
but we still have 20,000 new cases a day
it takes months to decrease the number
of cases dramatically if wave 2 is
expected in mid-september
there probably won't even be a break
between waves 1 & 2 in some of these
states Florida may be one of those
places I don't know
so in the other states that are doing
well it's going to start to be affected
by our people traveling in from problem
states and giving the virus to other
people like if people start coming to
Florida of to Massachusetts from Florida
that could be a major problem and do
people in the states that are doing
better start disregarding the rules so
that's what it's going to depend on now
in terms of Miami I just got an email
today in fact from the hotel that I stay
and when I go to Miami Beach and they
are offering 15% off and you know saying
we're open again and it's all happening
and it's all great and needless to say
I'm not booking any hotel stays in Miami
Beach right now but it died am getting
the impression that it's just back to
normal there yeah everything's kind of I
mean I wouldn't say hundred percent
normal but it's it's weird because I
feel like though everyone's world view
is changing yeah and I think it's
because Miami is one of those cities
that you know has a lot of people but
wasn't like a New York or anything like
that so it I guess people are just kind
of like but then like nothing's
happening so right now in Miami or so
are you in Miami or Miami Beach I'm in
Miami like basically Miami Beach couple
miles away okay yeah I don't know if
you're spending time more in one or the
other but so right now people are dining
in doors with no masks and not a reduced
number of tables it's like the full
number of tables oh it's probably like
safe space it up instead of like candles
like in a restaurant open like hand
sanitizer
but it's it's deafening like nothing's
happening right guys you start to wear a
mask to go in okay once you're seated
there's no mask I mean the AC could
still flow a certain way which is right
think that's how people contracted the
virus in Washington yep AC like spread
everything so don't worry what are you
doing are you are you dining indoors
right now or are you avoiding it
I mean I'm avoiding it but it's kind of
hard to like you know my my sister she
might go dine in and I might interact
with her so like everyone's kind of
doing their own thing so yeah
you might think steps to prevents them
but they like it people around you all
the time are doing stuff I mean can you
really help it no you can't and I mean
this is why the case numbers are what
they are it's like the spike in floor it
almost looks fake like do you see how
fast the cases are going up and it's
like could that even be real like yeah
it's real it's crazy and my girlfriend
works for like the sort of apartments me
taking seriously but I see the emails
like they're spikes and you know the
protests don't help either
summertime some people like this I guess
not wearing masks either because by
having a thought it's like 89 degrees
outside right now man that's such a
bummer I wasn't really scheduled to be
in Miami Beach
I was supposed to go March wait March
March 25th no yeah right around March
25th I had tickets and a hotel stay
booked for Miami Beach and things
exploded around March you know 10 or 12
and obviously it didn't happen I
cancelled it and I don't know when I
will next be down there which is really
sad because I do like it well my
question hopefully things get better but
I think everyone's world view is not
helping the situation anymore I agree I
agree all right good luck down in Miami
wishing everybody the best down there it
seems like a very very complicated
situation to say the least we're gonna
go to a break I apologize I wasn't able
to get to everybody who called in but I
did my best and we will take calls again
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
okay let's get right into audience
questions first one today David I've
heard you say that the stock market does
better with Democratic presidents than
Republican does the country always do
better when there is a Democratic
president economically so we have to
know what metrics were looking at what
when we try to measure how the country
is doing there are a number of different
indicators that we would look at no one
indicator tells us everything we need to
know we would look at GDP growth
unemployment and stock market
performance certainly as indicators we
would probably take a look at what
portion of the country is poor below the
poverty line what's the degree of
inequality there are other metrics that
can be a little squishier because they
relate to others so we could say well
how strong is the dollar but that would
be related to our a trade deficit or
surplus and it's harder to say we're
doing well or were not without kind of a
more systemic approach and then you've
got intangibles right like how respected
are we around the world right now
respect for the United States is very
very low because of Donald Trump how do
you sort of price that into the equation
but to pick a few of these indicators
yes the stock market does better under
Democratic presidents than Republicans a
lot of people don't care about the stock
market the stock market is not the
economy as we have very clearly seen
during the last three months of
coronavirus but the return the
annualized return during Democratic
administrations has been fourteen point
three percent whereas it has been ten
point eight percent under Republicans so
yes the stock market does better under
Democrats in terms of GDP growth GDP
growth is significantly higher under
Democratic presidents than Republican
presidents typically it depends on
exactly how you measure and and certain
timing issues but it's anywhere from
fifteen to forty four percent larger GDP
growth during Democratic presidential
administrations then republican in terms
of unemployment unemployment tends to be
higher during Republican administrations
eighteen
percent higher by one study that I
looked at in terms of job creation
remember jobs created and the
unemployment rate are two different
things since World War two Democratic
presidents have seen more than a twenty
four point four million more jobs
created during their watch that's an
average of seventy eight percent more
jobs created per year of Democratic
administrations versus Republican
administrations so yeah by those
indicators we do better with Democratic
presidents now the thing is somebody
believes Republicans are just better for
the economy these data won't convince
them they'll say well some of that is
because of lag time you see better
metrics when a Democrat takes over
because of the policies the Republican
put in place this has been pretty widely
debunked but still people continue to
repeat it you will sometimes hear well
Democrats spend in order to make some of
these metrics look better well it's like
if you trust the metrics and government
spending improves the metrics then
that's good right I mean they would the
right will try to argue that these are
sort of like cheap ways to quote improve
the economy which sounds crazy I mean it
literally sounds crazy other metrics
like poverty I mean the thing about
poverty is if I change the poverty level
if I say well instead of being poor at
fifteen thousand dollars a year you're
only poor below twelve I've just taken
millions of people out of poverty I've
not really changed anything so that's
why poverty is not really the the best
metric inequality is important but as
always you know mean median mode looking
at something like the Guinea index GI ni
there's different ways to look at that
but in short yeah I mean the traditional
indicators that we look at suggests that
the economy does better when we have a
Democratic president than a Republican
president since the early 1900s when we
have
you know more or less or really even the
World War 2 era we would say when things
are sort of measured in in the same way
and you can always I mean the reason I'm
sort of hesitating is that this question
is inherently fraught because any
empirical differences you can point to
can be explained away by motivated
reasoning and so it's a fair question
but it's a really difficult one to
convince anybody about in a way that
would materially change their
perspectives on what the right policies
are next question is about Joe Biden
Donald Trump and Utah David if Mitt
Romney endorses Biden could Biden win
Utah so the answer is no the short
answer is no and the background for the
question I understand there was recently
a poll that showed in very very
right-wing conservative Utah Donald
Trump winning only by three points the
idea about Mitt Romney is Mitt Romney is
a Republican senator from Utah Mitt
Romney's Mormon Utah has a big Mormon
population Mormons maybe what while
disproportionately Republican voters
they also may just follow what Mitt
Romney does if Mitt Romney says hey vote
for Biden could it turn Utah against
Donald Trump I don't I don't see it I
think the best case scenario would be if
Mitt Romney does endorse Joe Biden that
it makes Utah so competitive that Trump
has to spend money there and then that
means there's less money Trump can spend
in other places but the truth is that
since the year 2000 the only Democrat to
carry more than 30% even in Utah was
Obama in 2008 and he still lost like in
other words Democrats often don't even
get 30 in Utah and when Obama did he's
still lost very very significantly the
best we can hope for is that Mitt Romney
makes it a fight for Donald Trump and
now there is one other thing to think
about here imagine if Mitt Romney ran
third party that actually could take
away enough
from Trump in Utah that it could play
spoiler essentially and turn it over to
Joe Biden but the problem is that if
Mitt Romney ran third party he'd be
running third party I don't think he
would just run in Utah and he would risk
in places like Michigan and Wisconsin
and others giving the election
potentially potentially to Donald Trump
we just don't know it would be dicey and
I would be worried about it so I think
the best thing job Mitt Romney can do is
seems unlikely he's going to support
Donald Trump if he is going as a support
to a Biden just say it and I think that
that is all we can really hope for and
make Utah a fight make Trump spend some
money you know we talk about what's
going on with Amy McGrath and Mitch
McConnell in that Senate race in
Kentucky I it's possible Amy McGrath
could win it's an uphill battle in a
recent poll she was up one but with a
huge number of undecided and people not
yet really paying that much attention I
hope she wins but even if she doesn't if
it's this close Republicans will
probably have to funnel a bunch of
national money into Kentucky to defend a
seat that has historically been very
very safe for Republicans that's still
good even if you don't end up winning
the seat so that that's my take right
now I don't think there's any real way
that Joe Biden wins Utah but let's make
a Trump fight for it why not David we
often talk about the bloated US budget
what would you cut from the US budget if
given a choice so this is a difficult
conversation to have because the reality
about the budget is that everything is a
negotiation not all cuts are created
equal not all cuts save money sometimes
you actually have to spend money in
order to save money by increasing
efficiency so I think that that's
important to keep in mind it's also
really important to look at agencies and
see which agencies are actually doing
what they were put in place to do where
is their efficiency where is their
inefficiency what purposes do different
agencies and departments serve so this
is not coming from some you know small
government libertarian idea of let's
start cutting
apartments because we just want to make
government small this is the reality
that there's probably a lot of
consolidation and things that can be
moved around but just like to take the
lowest hanging fruit first the military
and Department of Defense obviously are
bloated and need to be cut we don't need
50 bases in Germany to the extent Trump
wants to reduce that I agree with that
the way in which it's done obviously is
the question we have a massive amount
the thing is it's just so easy to say
this it's like okay I'm on the left we
should cut the military we'll still be
safe I think it's more interesting to
look for example at cutting specifically
military contractor spending that's a
much more specific angle where the right
and many of the on the left in in
Congress just are absolutely tied to
these groups that lobby for more
military contractor spending that
specifically needs to be reduced
you can probably consolidate for example
you know does TSA Customs and Border
Patrol
people want ice abolished all together
there's probably a big opportunity there
to like dissolve reformulate consolidate
etc that would represent a cost savings
and then there's a bunch of spend money
to save money sort of considerations
there's a lot of stuff where we need
more money in the short term like
infrastructure upgrading buildings
switching federal buildings to renewable
energy etc etc we're in the short-term
we actually have to spend more over the
long-term we will save the problem with
these conversations about what to cut is
that once you understand you you can't
how do I want to say this everything's a
negotiation
there's tons of favors and amendments
and this is sort of like how policy is
done right now and to really cut
properly to have a shot at actually
cutting the types of spending that is
the problematic spending you need to
completely change so many aspects of our
political system and
there's a lot of good books written
about this and articles about it but you
know me listing stuff maybe is
interesting and I don't think I'd have
anything super surprising but what we
need to actually change is the way that
this system of cronyism and oh you know
wink wink I'll go for your amendment if
you go for mine and this port you know
everybody's put that the truth is we
talk about pork barrel projects
everybody's poor you know everybody's
pork is someone else's in many cases
community project right so you know I
get you to sign off on rebuilding some
ice rinks in my district and that seems
like pork if you're representing Hawaii
and I'm in Illinois but then you reverse
it and we have very similar situations
looking from Illinois over to Hawaii and
this is really part of the problem and
part of the problem of how budgeting is
done but all of that being said
Department of Defense military
absolutely huge opportunities to cut for
sure no question about it okay make sure
that you don't miss today's bonus show
which will be hosted by producer Pat you
can get instant access by becoming a
member at join pakman.com or a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
will be back on Monday later next week
we will be on a little David Pakman show
vacation we've not had one since the
start of coronavirus because there's
nothing to do and nowhere to go I will
be doing a little traveling within the
state with a mask and with with
everything rubber gloves the face
shields everything we'll tell you more
about that next week
pad on the bonus show today I'll be back
on Monday